hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
these trust is Big conference speech is
interrupted by climate protesters but
there's virtually zero on Net Zero from
her
a global rise in renewable energy in the
first half of the Year prevents any
increased need for fossil fuels
Parts Golden State how 94 of California
is now in severe or extreme droughts
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis so we start
and there are many reasons why Liz
truss's first conference speech as
leader attracted attention today from an
environmental point of view people
wanted to know what she'd say about the
UK's Net Zero pledge amid questions over
her green credentials and early in Her
speech two Greenpeace Representatives
addressed their concerns directly to the
new prime minister
let's get them removed
[Applause]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
and no doubt to the disappointment of
those environmental campaigners the
climate barely got so mentioned during
the speech and this was the sum total
we're opening more gas fields in the
North Sea and delivering more Renewables
and nuclear energy this is how we will
protect the Great British environment
deliver on our commitment to Net Zero
and Tackle climate change
[Applause]
well our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter is
here thanks for joining us today so most
people would have seen that Greenpeace
moment and they will say you know
they're holding the government to
account over their climate policy I
think there's a great deal of
frustration in the the campaigning
movement you know rewind a year ago
Boris Johnson Was preparing for the cop
26 U.N climate Summit in Glasgow amid
great Fanfare position in the UK is a
global leader on climate change and now
we're in a really different place Liz
truss seems set on bringing in a new era
of fossil fuel exploration in the UK
lifted the moratorium on fracking she's
handing out new licenses or planning to
at least for oil and gas drilling you
know in the North Sea she's also ordered
a review of the UK's legally enshrined
Net Zero carbon emissions by 2050 Target
and she's doing that she says to ensure
that that Target and policy remains
pro-growth and pro-business which is
language we very much heard echoed in
her dismissal of those Greenpeace
protesters she said you are part or they
are part of the anti-growth Coalition as
relatively new language campaigners will
be really concerned that the government
is starting to frame those with a green
agenda as somehow anti-business when
Boris Johnson for example was often
painting tackling climate change as a
huge Economic Opportunity let's have a
listen now to what one of the protesters
who was there in the hall with listruss
said to Sky News
this year we felt like we really needed
to take a different approach and take a
direct message to the prime minister to
say who voted for this who voted for
what Liz truss and her cabinet are
trying to roll out across the country
nobody voted for fracking nobody voted
to trash nature nobody voted to cut
benefits nobody voted to slash workers
rights yet somehow Liz trust seems to
think that that's okay and she's seems
to be hell-bent on rolling this stuff
out across the economy and we needed to
come in there and send a message on
behalf of the public
Hannah while you're here could we talk
about alok Sharma the president of cop
26 and a member of the prime minister's
cabinet he's come out and said that
actually King Charles III should go to
cop27 along with the Prime Minister yes
this all stems from reporting that Liz
truss apparently asked King Charles not
to go to cop 27 despite him being
famously passionate about environmental
causes and despite having been invited
uh there's been no confirmation either
way about the exact detail of that
conversation but we do know that King
Charles is not going
um alok Sharma who is a cabinet minister
in the conservative government has said
really clearly speaking from a different
conference in Democratic Republic of
Congo I would certainly welcome the
king's attendance and I know that many
people around the world see him as a
leader in this area and it just speaks
to the strength of feeling I think that
he would undercut his prime minister at
this moment of political Jeopardy for
the party and let's trust herself so so
interesting Hannah thank you so much
now with the cop27 the UN climate Summit
well it begins isn't it a month tomorrow
in the Egyptian Red Sea Resorts of charm
El Sheikh and a sponsorship deal between
this year's conference in Coca-Cola has
been branded greenwash by campaigners so
Environmental Group say Coke is one of
the world's biggest uses of plastic and
a petition was launched at last year's
cop calling for an end to corporate
sponsorship of the talks and Coca-Cola
has told Sky News that by 2030 it will
collect and recycle a bottle or a can
for everyone sold regardless of where it
comes from the other company also
pledged to reduce absolute carbon
emissions by a quarter by 2030.
hey Pakistan's climate change Minister
says the country has run out of money to
spend on recovery from recent
devastating floods and asked for prompt
International Help At the launch of a un
aid appeal Sherry Raymond urged the
developed world to accelerate funding
for the disaster which she said had no
parallel in known history and our
meeting was told that the UN has only
received 90 million dollars so far
and Thai authorities have warned of
possible serious floods in Bangkok and
Central areas ahead of expected heavy
seasonal rainfall through the rest of
the week now the situation has been
worsened by a large volume of water
moving down from flooding in the north
of the country an estimated 160
000 hectares of agricultural land was
hit by flooding which damaged more than
80 000 homes
so listen we may be in the grips of an
energy crisis but there's some rare good
news today when it comes to renewable so
in the first half of this year a rise in
renewable energy that solar wind and
hydro electric power well it prevented
any need for growth in coal and gas
generation for power and that's
worldwide and in China wind and solar
energy even led to a fall in the use of
fossil fuels so arise in wind and solar
generation met three quarters of the
increased demand for energy while
Hydromet the remainder and the combined
increase in renewable energy prevented a
four percent increase in fossil fuel
generation and saved 40 billion dollars
in fuel costs and 230 million tons of
CO2 emissions that's great news Well
climate reporter Victoria Seabrook is
here I mean it doesn't get much better
than that at this stage does it exactly
this is significant and it is good news
because this is all about clean power
slowly muscling out fossil fuels and the
pollution and the global warming that
comes with that so that clean power is
being built absolutely at scale and at
PACE that's because it is clean and it's
very cheap to build so solar power has
fallen in costs by about 90 in a decade
and it's solar and wind that places like
China and the US huge countries are
building
so this means that although electricity
demand grew this year in the first half
of this year by about three percent
actually all of that increase in demand
was met by Renewable Power which meant
no we didn't need any increase in fossil
fuel power or the emissions that that
comes with that so emissions did not
grow in the power sector in the first
half of this year that's huge and
experts say we're reaching that Tipping
Point where soon not only will we meet
the new demand but we'll be able to
displace existing demand fossil fuel use
will fall so will the emissions and the
and the rate of global warming that
comes with that so this all goes to show
that although a lot of the time the
outlook on the climate can feel very
Bleak and indeed it is when you look at
the science when you look at the impacts
you just have to look at Pakistan and
flooding flooding in Pakistan drought in
Europe the energy crisis but at the same
time we've got this rapid transformation
in technology the transition to clean
Power electric vehicles heat pumps and
so on all of these things that we're
going to need to curb global warming so
this is this is some welcome calls for
optimism on the right track Victoria
thank you very much for that
now there are fears for safety of rural
communities across California as a
severe drought continues to grip the
state and it's led to more people having
to drill for groundwater as the
reservoirs are heavily depleted but now
heavy pumping is draining the
underground aquifers and in some cases
cutting off communities entirely so
according to a U.S drought monitors more
than 94 of the states is in severe or
extreme drought and more than 1 200
Wells have run dry this year that's
Statewide and that's a 57 increase on
last year and by contrast fewer than 100
dry Wells were reported annually that's
in 2018 2019 and 2020 will Skies Becky
Cottrell has more without water
communities across rural California are
being forced to go without
this was once a canal now just dry
cracked Earth a death sentence for a
nearby Orchard and a serious threat to
local livelihoods well this year we've
actually lost two worlds within this
last month this one and the one at my
other boys place his is dry
so everybody's borrowing and using water
someplace else
but it's not just food supply that's at
risk everyday life has been upended you
can see no water no water
Thomas charez's tenants have had no
running water for two years they're
surviving bringing water uh from a
neighbor about 1500 feet from here and
I'm paying for the wallet so they do it
on the daily basis they carry their own
five gallons on their own cars
Californians are having to drill deeper
in search of water but for families and
businesses that rely on Wells there can
be a long wait to install a new one
and as climate change brings more severe
droughts people here and in other parts
of the world will suffer as they watch
their water supplies dry up Becky
Cottrell Sky News
well that's all for today thanks very
much for watching